a little bit of a a situation that
unfolded last night some of you guys
were privy to this
i had fun i hope you guys had fun
but uh you know last night i was
watching uh davey croco stream with wild
smile
by the way two guys that uh i'm very big
fans of
uh not only um
but um we were having a little fun last
night
at the expense of uh jeremy the
quartering
and uh everybody was getting in on this
action i mean it was
it started with me [ __ ] with them and
davey croco was fun with them
and andy warski jumped it and me and
warski were going hard on him i think
the hardest
ethan ralph jumped in like it just
became this [ __ ]
pylon of people [ __ ] with the
quartering
and honestly i fee it's
it's my fault i started it so it's
definitely my fault but like
i didn't even mean to
start whatever the [ __ ] i started right
i literally tweeted
out one thing last night i'm just trying
to find it now
uh here it is this was my tweet last
night
this tweet okay for some reason
started world war three on twitter
so um i was as i was saying i was
watching davey croco and wild smile too
guys i
i'm fans of their work i'm also fans of
them as people
uh very cool guys so you know i like to
support people and uh
support our friends so got done with the
show last night and then you know davey
croco's live so you know i tweeted it
out and i'm like
i'll go pop in i'll you know i'll throw
him a stream labs i'll watch a little
bit before i go play video games
and he's playing this clip of uh the
quartering
and i'm like he's not really wearing
this hat right so he's
those you can see he's wearing a hat in
his video about this was about tin pool
whereas hat said uh meme war
veteran which this is like this was the
cringiest thing i've seen in a [ __ ]
long time so i couldn't i couldn't
resist
and i tagged him in this tweet and i all
i wrote was
bro sweet hat
that's all i felt like just not even
going really hard on the guy
not being that much of a dick just hey
bro
sweetheart because it's just
just let the thing [ __ ] speak for
itself right
um
[Music]
he's a maid so
i i couldn't let this this [ __ ] made me
laugh so
uh andy warski jumped in saying my soul
cringes
and then the quarter and got really
pissed off at that
and uh decided to start yelling at
warski
a lot of you guys ended up getting
retweets from him though so that's um
so that's kind of funny but uh
so andy warski wrote my soul cringes the
quartering fired back getting roasted by
andy warski has never meant
less i wish you the best dude hopefully
you get your life back
on track ah the old taking the high road
attacked
gotta love that
taking the old high road oh gee
i wish you the best i hope you get your
life back on track
man um
so we all started busting his chops
warski said his wife should divorce him
for that ad which that made me laugh
uh and dude he just started retweet sub
tweeting and replying to
every individual insult directed at him
uh for the better part of the evening
last night i mean it was just non-stop
like i said i piled on ethan ralph piled
on
warski uh uh so cal chris
luck travis i mean just everybody was
piling on this idiot
and making fun of his cat
and then of course the quartering says
oh yeah right his wife should divorce
him uh
his wife for 12 years should divorce him
for wearing a hat their mutual friend
bought him for christmas
so of course i had to say to him that uh
if my own mother came back from the dead
and gave me that hat as a gift
uh i would have to throw it in the
garbage immediately
that i would rather wear a hat that says
registered sex offender on it
um so i don't does this guy
does i don't really watch the quartering
like i i
i talked to him a little bit when um
[Music]
you know when the [ __ ] uh magic the
gathering [ __ ] was going on with the
pedophiles and
i thought he did good work there
objectively i'm not gonna pretend
retroactively uh like i didn't think he
did great work on that
well we covered that a little bit on our
show when he started doing his thing
i thought it was you know i thought it
was good work outing people
i thought his motivation was pretty
obvious um
you know the only the only problem i had
with his stuff
uh with the magic the gathering stuff
it's like you know if you knew all this
stuff was going on
uh why did you wait until they kicked
you out before you went and ran to the
press um
it's that's one of those things where
like you know i mean like
so you knew that there were all these
pedos and they were like conducting all
these
[ __ ] tournaments or whatever with
these kids and you didn't care
until they kicked you out of the magic
the gathering tournaments and they kept
your money
and then you were like hey guys there's
pedophiles in there
so that was like my only issue with that
but
objectively it's pretty gross that these
people were
employing these disgusting folks so uh
you know we gave that some coverage
whatever but
does he have any self-awareness at all
like i don't i haven't
watched him since then but uh it just
seems like he just sucks tim paul's dick
now and wears cringy hats but
like what is his uh what is his problem
bendy says he hired pewdiepie's video
editor to try to get more views
um it's been fading from relevance since
the monday match [ __ ] storm yeah i mean
that's
again though that's why you really
shouldn't rely on uh e-drama
you know these these guys um
that's not just the quartering it's a
lot of these the blood sports types of
people
they rely way too much on the drama
itself
to keep people interested in their show
and in my opinion
you should be focused on being funny
being engaging having quality content
building a good
community like this you should be
focused on the content
and then when you get a moment of drama
capitalize on it get more eyes on your
show
but you gotta you know when the people
just constantly do the drama thing
it kind of wears thin after a while uh
he's he's debating apparently uh tim
poole's brother right now on the kill
stream
i don't care look we're gonna have uh
tim paul's brother on uh revenge of the
sis
uh i believe this week coming up he's
gonna come on and
tell his side of the story so um
you know looking forward to hearing that
i'll be honest with you i think both of
the pool brothers should [ __ ] cringe
if i'm being honest um
that's just how i feel it but if this
guy has some dirt on timpool
i'm all about it right like i don't if i
have to pick a side i'm picking
the non-tim poolside because he's a food
buck
food bucket shilling uh uh shill
basically and uh so
we're gonna have him on next week should
be um interesting and we'll see what he
has to say regarding this
uh subverse which by the way you guys
are like
i think the cringiest thing about the
pool brothers fighting each other
is the fact that you guys are fighting
over a dot-net domain
you know what i mean like holy [ __ ] it's
not even a dot-com
ah so i gotta i gotta loosen up my belt
a little bit i'm getting fat
um they're fighting over a dot-net
domain
which is really [ __ ] cringe to me um
but whatever they're they're having
their little battle
and uh you know look anything that
exposes tim poole
i'm [ __ ] game for so hopefully we'll
uh get him on next week and he'll have
uh whatever he has to say but and i just
want to update you we had jeremy uh
kind of freaking the [ __ ] out